i'm wondering if you can tell us the
story of how you're finishing up or
you've already finished with call me
king
and then you start writing lazarus or
how do you
how are you pitching this to investors
yeah i guess i
i had the idea for lazarus
[Music]
um as i was finishing call me king um
actually and um i had already started
started talking to uh
actor sean riggs and um
he's someone i've known for a long time
so i knew you know um
i knew we had planned on sort of
producing something together but
i wasn't sure what it was up until
around that time when call me king was
sort of coming out and um
it was actually a pretty easy process to
get funded um
just based on what we'd already done and
um
[Music]
you know the definitely the success of
call me king
it made it pretty easy uh it's probably
the
easiest i've gotten a a project funded
because uh um you know
we still had a lot of energy from it and
actually the investor of
lazarus had seen call me king you know
so
um yeah it was it happened pretty
quickly
actually like um i had the
the story the concept in mind but i i
hadn't written it yet
um and um
you know once uh once call me king was
done it sort of
made it made its his its uh rounds
um i kind of yeah quickly moved into
lazarus and
yeah we were up and running uh pretty
quickly actually
um yeah and and all that stuff was sort
of coming together like the
idea of creating a universe um
um i knew that i knew the first hero in
that universe i wanted to come for me
and then i wanted to start to bring in
um other uh concepts from other
independent like comic book creators and
stuff like that um
and so uh yeah yeah it came together
pretty pretty fast actually
yeah you're writing the script yeah yeah
how
um so so yeah i uh i had the idea
i sort of took that same approach did an
outline
and just started writing and um
[Music]
it took me um probably a few months
actually um to finish that script but as
as i was finishing it you know we were
already um getting funding and
sort of um getting ready
yeah we it got funded kind of just off
the idea of it
you know um the idea of it and then the
success of
call me king was like okay you know
did you approach the investors or did
they approach you yeah we approached
them um
you know it was interesting because um
some of the discussions that came from
uh call me king was like hey if you guys
are doing you know something else like
you know whatever you're doing next like
we you know we love to talk about it or
um let me know you know what's going on
after that
so um yeah as soon as we
had sort of decided to move forward
lazarus like
um once i had the idea sort of fleshed
out like we
went to certain people and we're like
hey this is what we're doing next you
know what i mean
and so um yeah they
they got on board you know pretty
quickly
what's the idea for the film what were
you pitching them that was just the idea
like how did you go in and present it
i had a bit of like concept art and i
had um
this uh sort of the i had uh
done sort of like a detailed uh synopsis
of the film um so i was able to sort of
break down the story and
um how everything sort of played out um
i had a i had a ballpark of what it
would take to make the film
um and um
the fact that it was in the superhero
genre you know that was like super
appealing
to people um especially with um
uh how um
popular the genre become by then
um so um i think that was one of the
biggest things that intrigued them was
like sort of
my idea and my approach to it but the
fact that it was uh
a superhero and a hero of color as well
um
and and it sort of lived in that space
so i call it a superhero thriller
because
it's it does have like some horror uh
undertone uh you know
and and so um yeah i think
that those were the things that really
sold
the idea of it um
was the genre if i if i was
making maybe another gangster film or
something maybe it would have took a
little more
nudging maybe maybe not i don't know but
um
but the fact that it was in the
superhero genre like people got really
excited about that
and what what's the film about oh
oh i'm trying to give too much away okay
um essentially it's a
uh
a city it's it's like a um
it's called paradise city it's a city
that's
sort of like in the heart of
like a chicago or like a la
and uh this whole city is sort of
uh overrun by uh
crime and it it's a bad place you know
and there's a synthetic
uh drug that you
you burn it and you sort of
uh the crystals produces red smoke and
you inhale it and it
uh it's like mind-altering and so uh
you know the whole infrastructure of the
city is sort of based upon
um that and the people who who operated
and they used a lot of the
people in the city as runners you know
they recruited a lot of people to
to work for them um and so our main
character
um ray lazarus like he
uh was like a military uh
vet he was a sort of a bad person before
he went to the military
and then he saw a lot of things and grew
up um
and became a better person so when he
came back he
uh was a totally different uh human
being and um
got a lot of his friends to to to go
legit and change their lives and you
know just like a very productive
uh citizen and um
[Music]
they tried to recruit him he said no and
something very bad happens to him and
um that sort of sends him on this dirty
uh
to undo like a lot of what's going on in
the city
um but
[Music]
in that moment where he's um
where this bad thing happens to him he's
approached by an entity
and this entity sends him on this
course uh but it has its own agenda
you know what i mean um
that's kind of all i could say really i
probably said too much but um
um but yeah it's uh but he's he's like
the super powered
being that is trying to free like this
city
um from the people that
have uh have sort of enslaved this city
through this
this synthetic drug
you